my first questions for you how long did
you work on your Bruce Willis impression
well first of all not to mince words but
we didn't want it to be an impression we
thought that would be sort of
distracting but we wanted to make a
character that felt like him and I did
work on it for a long time actually um
you know I would watch his movies I
would rip the audio off of his movies
and put him on the ipod so I could
listen on repeat and Bruce even sent me
he recorded himself record doing some of
my voiceover monologues and sent me that
recording so i could hear that but the
most useful thing was just spending time
with him and hanging out with them and
you know having dinner and letting it
seep in that way so you know obviously
you both work together on brick ghetto
quite a few years ago now and in the
meantime you know he's become sort of
kind of like a sci-fi genre sort of
guide you feel like he kind of lucked
out you know that you want to make a
sci-fi maybe at the time he had just
done like inception prizes and it was
kind of really yeah it was a real stroke
of luck I guess but yeah even if he had
just been doing other things I guess
courtroom dramas or musically yes i did
still have put him in this thing is uh
this kid can do anything else Thanks
well one of the things that I mean one
of the things that I often say about Joe
usually while he's not around is that
he's got kind of that leading man
charisma but his heart he's a character
actor and he loves disappearing into
parts and just slapped me if I say
anything that's incorrect at any point
but and this was a chance for him to do
that on a large scale literally putting
on another actor's face so I knew he'd
be into it it seems like you're making a
step towards doing a lot of you know
sci-fi and genre or something is that so
are you drawn to those kind of those
kind of rules you know I like all kinds
of genres i mean really any genre has
its virtues this is what you do with it
I don't think there's any one particular
one that I like more than the other like
Stanley Kubrick all of his movies or
genre movies and all of all three of
Ryan's movies have been in different
genres too and I think it's about using
a genre as a springboard to get to
what's ultimately a drama you know the
dark knight rises is in the genre of a
superhero film but ultimately it's it's
a drama
looper is in the genre of a sci-fi time
travel movie but ultimately it's about
the human characters and the story in
the drama yeah you know what talk about
about the tech in the film I think one
of the things I was really fascinated by
was that some things were updated you
know there are very fancy phones and
very fancy sort of you know television
screens as have like that but then
trucks that were just sort of hacked
together to be you know but you know how
much did you sort of want to create a
world that looked real that way well
it's important yeah we were trying to
create a really grounded near future
dystopia and so that involved yeah just
thinking step-by-step okay what will the
cars look like well most of them will
probably be like the yank tanks in Cuba
where we've had to make these cars last
for 30 years and so they have new
engines jammed inside and panels bound
the top but even the futuristic stuff
that we built into it we tried to kind
of knock down a little like there's
hoverbikes but they kind of don't work
that well and then they can't they're
not actually that good and the phones
they still don't get reception I know so
every element we tried to knock down the
peg and ground a little bit obviously
this movie deals with time travel if
time travel weren't vented tomorrow
would you go back and where I would want
to see the future okay if that's a lab
yeah yeah likewise I would only mess the
pass it up past up I'm very happy where
I am right now I don't want the mutt get
anything up let's let's let's see what
the iphone 12 is go for the few years
how far hundred years 200 a hundreds a
nice round number right yeah why go too
far cuz then you end up just on that
charred piece of Earth and it is all
alone but like where did everybody go
ever is it off where are these giraffe
o'clock in the earth what's happening